bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat aujourd'hui les
sénateurs poursuivent l'examen du budget
pour 2015 après avoir adopté la première
partie la partie consacrée aux recettes
la semaine dernière et bien il s'attaque
depuis à peu près une semaine au crédit
démission un par un en clair au dépenses
place ce matin à l'enseignement scolaire
à l'éducation nationale l'une des
priorités du quinquennat de François
Hollande qui rappelons-le a promis la
création de 60 000 postes en 5 ans rien
que l'année prochaine et bien ce sont
pas moins de 10000 postes qui doivent
être créés pour un coût d'environ 125
millions d'euros une politique du
chiffre selon les rapporteurs UMPS des
commissions des finances et de la
culture Gérard Longuet Jean-Claude Karl
une politique qui estime-t-il va à
l'encontre de la réduction des déficits
il propose eux à la place et bien une
réduction des dépenses de 165 millions
d'euros autre sujet qui va être sur la
table ce matin et bien le poids de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires sur les
collectivités locales la semaine
dernière lors du congrès des maires de
France et bien Manuel Valls le Premier
ministre a promis de pérenniser le fond
d'amorçage qui était destiné aux
communes dans ce cadre un amendement
vient d'ailleurs concrétiser cette
promesse tout de suite donc on prend la
direction de l'hémicycle
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion de projets de loi des
finances pour 2015 adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale le Sénat va
examiner les crédits de la mission
enseignement scolaire article 55 la
parole est à Monsieur Gérard Longuet
rapporteur spécial de la commission des
finances pour 10 minutes
bien monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues en 10
minutes je n'aurai pas la prétention
d'être exhaustif et je crains même
d'être brutal alors que cette mission
est une mission passionnante qui est au
cœur même de notre vie sociale au cœur
des préoccupations de la République et
qui est préoccupation partagée par
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes mais les
règles du procédé en budgétaire impose
cet exercice mon approche sera donc
celle d'un analyse d'un auditeur
financier qui ne s'appuiera que sur des
analyses chiffrées pour essayer dans
d'en sortir au nom de la commission des
finances un certain nombre
d'orientations et d'observations ce qui
est vrai d'abord madame le ministre
c'est que votre ministère fait un très
bon travail en matière de de
statistiques et la publication annuelle
de l'état de l'école est un outil de
référence excellent c'est une création
de Monsieur Jospin d'ailleurs donc je le
cite de bon cœur monsieur le rapporteur
de la commission des affaires
culturelles et je m'appuierai donc
essentiellement sur des chiffres de
l'OCDE et sur des comparaisons
nationales sur la dépense d'éducation
dans notre pays
sur l'OCDE
l'étude pizza est devenue aujourd'hui un
rendez-vous incontournable pour avoir
exercé Madame le Ministre ce rapport il
y a quelques années on parlait de pizza
avec suspicion dénigré aujourd'hui on
retient et après tout c'est une un
progrès puisque c'est un indicateur qui
nous est extérieur qui s'impose à nous
on peut le contester comme le classement
de Shanghai il le mérite d'exister nous
rappeler un certain nombre d'évidences
et que nous dit-il et bien il nous dit
en gros que nos performances sont quand
même pas extraordinaires et que nous
avons une situation d'ensemble qui est
décevante tant sur la maîtrise des
connaissances que sur la le fossé qui se
creuse entre les bons et les mauvais
élèves
face à ce constat que sur lequel je ne
voudrais pas ma pesantir d'autres
orateurs y reviendront je voudrais
constater que nous dépensons autant que
les autres et parfois plus donc la seule
réponse quantitative qui consiste à dire
nous pourrions rattraper nos faiblesses
en dépensant plus et manifestement une
approche
erronée je n'en veux pour seul exemple
que la comparaison avec notre voisin
immédiat l'Allemagne qui dépense 5,1% de
son PIB alors que nous dépensons toutes
origines confondue l'État les
collectivités locales les familles et
parfois les employeurs le 6,1% de notre
PIB pour l'éducation au sens large et
nous on passe simplement pour
l'enseignement scolaire nous avons donc
à nous poser la question de la
performance simplement et ce sont des
chiffres qui sont tirés de votre propre
document nous dépensions toutes origines
confondues par élève 4500 euros en 1980
en constant pardonnez-moi et aujourd'hui
en 2014 nous sommes à 8300 euros nous
avons pratiquement un doublement peut-on
dire pour autant que les résultats et
suivi cet effort de l'ensemble de la
collectivité que ce soit l'état les
familles ou les collectivités locales
alors avant d'attaquer une réflexion
peut-être plus qualitative reconnaissons
que notre pays est étonnant de la
commission des finances que je le dis
notre pays a des contraintes spécifiques
qui méritent d'être retenu sinon nous
passerions à côté de la vérité du coût
de l'enseignement ces contraintes
spécifiques c'est naturellement la
dispersion géographique nous sommes le
plus grand territoire la densité sans
doute une des densités les plus faibles
de l'Union européenne et cette densité
faible aboutit à une dispersion de
l'offre scolaire j'ajoute que nous les
élus en général et les sénateurs en
particulier sommes les alliés objectifs
de la dispersion scolaire tant nous
sommes attachés au maintien
le sol de classe de collège et parfois
de lycée de section de lycée alors que
la raison nous conduirait à accepter des
regroupements les attitudes ont beaucoup
changé ayant Madame le Ministre le
privilège de la longévité parlementaire
je puis constater que nos élus locaux
acceptent aujourd'hui les regroupements
pédagogiques intégrés sur site et dans
en milieu rural par exemple nous avons
en général de plus en plus une école
cantonale et non plus une école
communale mais cette dispersion
géographique est une contrainte elle
pèse nous avons la chance d'avoir une
démographie positive de nombreux jeunes
ce qui explique en partie la différence
par exemple avec des pays plus vieux
comme l'Allemagne qui dépense évidemment
moins en matière d'enseignement au
regard de leur PIB parce qu'ils ont
moins de jeunes mais ils dépensent plus
par élève il dépense plus parlait donc
si on fait la comparaison on s'aperçoit
que tout n'est pas parfait dans cette
démographie vous avez Madame le Ministre
à la commission des finances le
reconnaît une difficulté particulière
c'est démographie française n'évolue pas
sur l'ensemble de territoire de l'OM
façon et que vous avez des régions qui
n'ont plus d'élèves mais qui veulent
garder leur professeur et les régions
qui ont de nouveaux élèves et qui
attendent toujours leurs professeurs qui
naturellement sont ailleurs puisque nous
nous les gardons dans les endroits où il
n'y a plus d'élèves je pète coupable en
tant que représentant d'une région dont
la démographie est stable et qui
naturellement cherche à garder son
réseau d'enseignement la deuxième raison
au-delà de la dispersion géographique
qui est beaucoup plus grave et qui elle
relève de votre ministère c'est la
dispersion de l'offre de l'enseignement
dans la diversité des enseignements et
alors là nous touchons un problème qui
est caractéristique de la France et qui
concerne principalement mais pas le
secondaire nous avons une offre
secondaire qui est peut-être d'une très
grande qualité je ne porterai pas de
jugement mais qui mathématiquement se
traduit par une diversité de Love un
très un petit nombre d'élèves par
enseignants qu'il faut complètement
statistiques nationales et qui aboutit
en effet à un surcoût de l'enseignement
français à raison du poids de du
secondaire par rapport aux primaires en
particulier qui est plutôt moins bien
traitée j'ajouterai enfin après la
dispersion géographique la dispersion de
l'offre scolaire la dispersion des
missions la France aime son état elle
aime son éducation nationale elle lui
confie beaucoup trop de missions y
compris dirais-je brièvement pour ne pas
allonger le débat et ne pas ouvrir de
polémique inutile un enseignement
prélementaire qui parfois s'apparente
selon ses détracteurs à de la garderie à
bon marché nous avons mais oui je sais
bien que je provoquais mais en 10
minutes on épuisera pas le fond du sujet
mais il faut quand même se poser la
question de les de la difficulté de la
faiblesse de notre primaire et de ce que
devrait être un pré élémentaire orienté
vers le succès du primaire et non pas
orienté vers l'accueil des tout-petits
pour avoir des effectifs
j'ajoute enfin que nous avons une
éducation nationale qui sert de support
à de nombreuses activités l'éducation
nationale peut-elle à une seule corrigée
et les faiblesses de notre société
parfois ces excès parfois ces injustices
la réponse est manifestement non et il
faudrait que l'intégration de
l'éducation nationale dans le tissu
local avec l'appui des familles et
l'appui des collectivités locales soient
plus judicieux mais qu'on ne charge pas
toujours la dette et qu'on ne se tourne
pas toujours vers les établissements
d'enseignement pour leur demander de
prendre en charge ce que la société ne
prend pas je voudrais avant d'attaquer
les chiffres exprime une conviction plus
personnelle c'est que l'élithisme
républicain est un atout pour la société
française qu'il ne faut pas le gommer
qu'il ne faut pas l'écarter qu'il faut
s'efforcer de le construire y compris
avec des formules traditionnelles qui
ont fait leurs preuves je pense à
l'internat alors d'excellence de
réussite ou l'internat le plus courant
pour faire en sorte que les élèves et
les jeunes garçons en particulier soit
je suis père et grand-père soit plongé
dans une ambiance de scolarité une
ambiance de studieuse ce qui
manifestement dans la vie d'aujourd'hui
et parfois difficile compte tenu des de
la l'immense diversité des loisirs qui
sollicitent le jeûne et de la faiblesse
du soutien familial par trop souvent
pour des raisons que je n'ai pas à juger
à cet instant je voudrais défendre
l'enseignement en alternance que
l'éducation nationale assume
partiellement mais c'est une une assez
bonne formule et je voudrais défendre le
soutien scolaire sur place nous avons
été sollicités par de très nombreux élus
locaux qui s'étonnent que les activités
périscolaires écartent le soutien
scolaire ou ne l'accepte pas ou semble
parfois même l'évincé ce qui est une
absurdité l'école est un lieu où ben oui
ça coûte cher je sais bien mes conseils
existent pourquoi le encourager et
pourquoi l'écarter je voudrais enfin
dans ces convictions et avant d'attaquer
les chiffres je serai d'une grande
brièveté pour les chiffres exprime une
dernière conviction c'est que l'élément
essentiel du soutien et de la réussite
scolaire c'est l'établissement et je
crois que tout ce qui peut être fait
pour donner vie à l'établissement
autonomie à l'établissement
responsabilité au chef d'établissement
qui soit primaire collège ou lycée sera
Madame le Ministre parfaitement bien vu
par notre commission des finances alors
la commission des finances sur votre
budget même elle constate
que vous avez budgété naturellement des
créations d'emplois sans mettre pour
autant en œuvre l'ensemble du programme
que le président François Hollande alors
qu'il était candidat avait annoncé
apparemment nous avons une création de
9600 emplois sur cette année en réalité
si on se retourne sur les trois
dernières années mais je n'entrerai pas
dans le détail ce n'est pas le temps les
résultats cette
ces effectifs n'ont pas été réunis
aujourd'hui le Sénat a une nouvelle
majorité cette nouvelle de majorité
estime qu'en ce qui concerne
l'enseignement secondaire il n'est pas
nécessaire aujourd'hui de procéder à ses
créations nouvelles et qu'il vaut même
mieux revenir à la politique précédente
je imagine que vous ne serez pas
d'accord madame le ministre qui consiste
à exercer une pression sur les effectifs
de l'enseignement secondaire pour
aboutir à une remise en cause
d'un certain de défaillance de ou de
comment pourrais-je dire de dispersion
de moyens de l'enseignement secondaire
dans notre pays et c'est la raison pour
laquelle en accord avec mon collègue
Jean-Claude Karl rapporteur de la
commission des Affaires culturels nous
proposerons un amendement qui visera à
revenir sur la création d'emplois dans
le secondaire et à en tenir les
conséquences ce qui aboutirait madame le
ministre
a une diminution légère très légère mais
réelle des crédits de votre ministère et
qui forme en une sorte d'appel à une
réponse sur l'idée que vous avez de
donner à notre enseignement des chances
de succès comparable aux autres pays en
optimisant les moyens voilà
l'intervention de et sous réserve de
l'adoption de cet amendement la
commission des finances propose
l'adoption des crédits du ministère de
l'Enseignement scolaire merci mon cher
collègue
la parole est à Jean-Claude Karl
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
la culture de l'éducation de la
communication pour 5 minutes mon cher
collègue
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je souhaite tout
d'abord vous faire part d'un regret
celui de n'avoir que 5 minutes pour
m'exprimer en tant que rapporteur pour
avis sur un budget de 66,4 milliards ce
qui fait ce qui fait la minute ce qui
fait la minute à 11 milliards mais ce
budget qui demeure la première ligne du
budget de l'État et surtout le meilleur
investissement de la nation si je devais
juger votre action madame la ministre à
la lumière du montant de votre budget je
ne pourrais que vous féliciter
l'éducation nationale constitue un des
rares ministères dont les crédits
augmentent plus de virgal 4 % ceux qui
constitue un effort important dans le
contexte actuel toutefois je suis
convaincu je le répète que la valeur
d'un budget ne se mesure pas à l'aune du
montant de ces crédits depuis près de 20
ans je soutiens que l'inflation des
moyens se révèle sans effet sur la
situation de l'école en effet le quasi
doublement de la dépense d'éducation
depuis 1980 ne s'est pas traduit par une
amélioration des résultats des élèves au
contraire les évaluations
internationales comme pizza font état
des résultats moyens obtenus par les
jeunes français quand d'autres
évaluations montrent qu'une part
significative d'entre eux ne maîtrise
pas ou mal les savoirs fondamentaux plus
encore de tous les pays de l'OCDE la
France est le pays où le déterminisme
social est le plus fort les Français le
savent et le disent un récent sondage
montre que plus de 2 de nos compatriotes
sur 3 considèrent que l'école ne
garantit plus l'égalité des chances et
55% d'entre eux pensent qu'elle assure
de moins en moins son rôle de promotion
sociale certes ne cédant pas aux
pessimiste comme vous l'avez dit madame
la ministre mais sachons regarder
objectivement et sereinement la
situation comment accepter aujourd'hui
qu'un fils d'ouvriers est 17 fois moins
de chance d'intégrer une grande école
qu'un fils de cadre ou d'enseignants
comment se satisfaire du fait que la
première porte que poussera un jeune sur
4 sortant de formation sera celle de
Pôle emploi ni du fait que 150000 jeunes
quittent chaque année le système
scolaire sans qualification par de là le
coût financier le décrochage engageant
les finances de l'État ou heure de
hauteur de 30 milliards d'euros chaque
année c'est la cohésion sociale de la
nation qui est en jeu plutôt que la
multiplication des mesures d'affichage
et des écrans de fumées à l'instar des
rythmes scolaires des ABCD de l'égalité
de l'évaluation bienveillante dont on
sait qu'il n'apporteront aucune réponse
de fond au problème du système éducatif
c'est une véritable réforme qualitative
dont l'école a besoin aujourd'hui en ce
qui concerne la réforme des rythmes
scolaires je demande que soit abrogée la
condition d'un projet éducatif
territorial c'est une contrainte inutile
qui pénalisera les petites communes
l'association des mers ruraux s'en est
d'ailleurs
il faut ainsi s'attaquer au véritables
priorités que constitue la maîtrise des
fondamentaux lire et écrire compter et
la nécessaire revalorisation du métier
d'enseignant notamment dans le primaire
en effet la maîtrise des fondamentaux
dicte en grande partie le destin
scolaire de l'élève l'essentiel se joue
entre 4 et 7 ans il nous faut ainsi
mettre devant les élèves les enseignants
les mieux formés et les mieux considérés
possibles nous savons l'importance de
l'émette qu'en est-il de la formation
continue des enseignants madame la
ministre il s'agit également de revoir
l'allocation de moyens de notre système
éducatif qui demeure défaillantes les
comparaisons internationales mettent en
évidence une sous dotation importante de
l'enseignement primaire quand nos
dépenses en faveur du secondaire sont
bien supérieurs à la moyenne des pays
européens la priorité aux primaire que
vous affichez relève madame la ministre
plutôt de la fiction elle repose
essentiellement sur plus de mètres que
de classe dont l'efficacité au regard
des expérimentations et des précédents à
l'étranger et plus que discutable au
contraire les moyens supplémentaires
devraient être consacrés à des
initiatives ayant fait leur preuve à
l'instar de la réduction du nombre
d'élèves par classe la mise en place de
pédagogie différenciée pour les
décrocheurs ou la création d'un
véritable statut au profit du directeur
d'école ces derniers dans l'effet
d'entraînement est avéré attendent
toujours un véritable statut la
revalorisation du métier d'enseignant ne
passe pas uniquement par une
augmentation des salaires certes
nécessaires pour le primaire mais
surtout par une amélioration des
conditions de travail ainsi que la mise
en œuvre d'une gestion des ressources
humaines dignes de ce nom en affectant
les moins expérimentés dans les
établissements les plus défavorisés la
gestion actuelle accentue les inégalités
hormis le nécessaire rétablissement de
la formation initiale que je salue le
gouvernement m'a apporté que des
modifications superficielles au statut
des enseignants sans engager de
réflexion globale sur le métier enfin je
souhaiterais dire un mot de la médecine
scolaire qui demeure le parent pauvre du
système scolaire pour réussir l'élève
doit être bien dans sa tête comme dans
son corps les personnels de santé
scolaire sont confrontés à une crise du
recrutement et à une dégradation de
leurs conditions de travail c'est
pourquoi je propose un amendement visant
à préparer la revalorisation de ses
professions madame la ministre chère mes
chers collègues j'aurais tant à dire en
si peu de temps l'éducation nationale
premier investissement de la nation
mérite mieux qu'une matinée parents
consacrée à ses crédits aux côtés du
gouvernement quel qu'il soit les
parlementaires ont leur part de
responsabilité et leur rôle à jouer
c'est pourquoi je souhaiterais quel lieu
au Sénat chaque année au mois d'avril
avant les arbitrages budgétaires un
débat d'orientation sur l'éducation
nationale le Parlement doit se saisir de
ce sujet
important pour l'avenir de notre pays et
dont le président de la République a
fait une priorité nationale j'espère que
je pourrais madame la ministre prévaloir
de votre soutien dans cette démarche la
commission de la culture et d'éducation
vous propose donc d'adopter les crédits
de l'enseignement scolaire sous réserve
de l'adoption des amendements je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Françoise Ferrat
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
la culture de l'éducation et de la
communication pour 5 minutes ma chère
collègue
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
mes chers renseignements agricole au nom
de la commission de la culture pour la
14e année consécutive
vous savez également que j'ai toujours
eu à cœur de conserver un regard lucide
et impartial sur les budgets et les
textes qui ont très je ne vous
surprendrai pas en annonçant qu'il
s'agit là d'un budget favorable du moins
en apparence
les crédits du programme augmentent de
2,6% par rapport à la loi de finance
pour 2014
140 postes d'enseignants et 25
auxiliaires de vie scolaire seront créés
dans le contexte actuel il pourrait
s'agir d'un effort appréciable
je relève également un effort notable en
matière d'accompagnement des éléments
handicapés dont les crédits dédiés
augmentent de 17%
. ce budget s'inscrit également de le
respect des protocoles d'accord conclus
en 2013 avec les établissements privés
du temps plein et du rythme approprié
toutefois mes chers collègues derrière
cette hausse apparente des crédits se
fait jour une fragilisation croissante
de la situation des établissements ainsi
que de l'enseignement agricole dans son
ensemble en effet s'il est juste que
l'enseignement agricole participe à sa
mesure aux efforts de maîtrise de la
dépense publique il n'est pas acceptable
que cela passe par la mise à la charge
des établissements de dépenses relevant
normalement de l'État
ce budget ne prévoit pourtant en
réduisant de plus de moitié les crédits
couvrant les charges de pension pour les
emplois gagés et des centres de
formation d'apprentie les CFA et des
centres de formation professionnelle et
de promotion agricoles CFPPA à savoir
51,6% soit 3,39 millions d'euros ou en
perpéturant la soudotation chronique des
1247 assistant d'éducation
l'évolution des effectifs d'élèves
constitue une inquiétude profonde
en deçà d'un certain seuil le maintien
d'un réseau éducatif distinct de
l'éducation nationale n'aura plus de
sens quel que soit l'excellence de ces
formations et de ses résultats
or les évolutions des deux dernières
années sont nettement défavorables les
effectifs diminuent de 3,6% la dernière
rentrée après une légère hausse plus
0,7% en 2013
une fois ces chiffres corrigés des
effets de la rénovation de la voie
professionnelle une tendance
structurelle à la baisse des effectifs
se fait jour qui touche tout
particulièrement les classes dites
d'appel que sur les classes de collège
et celle de ce groupe la raison est
simple les élèves ne sont plus orientés
vers les formations proposées par
l'enseignement agricole il s'agit là
d'un choix délibéré de l'éducation
nationale
visant à retarder le plus possible
l'orientation des élèves
j'anticipe les dénégations que vous nous
poserez madame la ministre j'affirme que
dans certaines académies comme Toulouse
Bordeaux et d'autres la réduction du
nombre d'élèves orientés vers
l'enseignement agricole et les MFR
constituent un objectif explicite fixé
dans le cadre du dialogue de gestion
si nous souhaitons que l'enseignement
agricole se maintienne et prospères il
faut que les élèves y soient orientés
pour ce faire il faut leur dire la
vérité à savoir qu'il s'agit là d'une
véritable filière d'excellence au
débouché nombreux vers de nouveaux
métiers et non pas une voie de
remédiation formant uniquement des
exploitants agricoles qui d'ailleurs je
vous l'indique encore s'il en était
besoin ne représente que 20% des
effectifs il faut faire savoir aux
élèves que l'insertion professionnelle
des diplômés de l'enseignement agricole
demeurent bien supérieure à d'autres
enfin l'absence d'ambition et de
perspective pour l'enseignement agricole
le condamne à une lente dégradation de
sa situation qui est alimentée par une
logique de régression qui tente à
adapter les effectifs au moyen alors
qu'il conviendrait de faire l'inverse en
cela la loi d'avenir pour l'agriculture
constitue une mer déception comme le
projet stratégique national présenté fin
2013 devant le Conseil national de
l'enseignement agricole knea qui n'a
fait l'objet d'aucun vote et dont la
portée demeure particulièrement
incertaine
en conclusion mes chers collègues
l'enseignement agricole est à la croisée
des chemins il nous appartient avec le
gouvernement d'assurer la pérennité de
cette filière d'excellence et
d'innovation alors que l'enseignement
agricole est appelé à jouer un rôle
majeur dans les défis que nous aurons à
relever et notamment la transition vers
la gros écologie j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir en vous présentant l'amendement
de notre Commission visant à rétablir
les crédits du programme dans leur
montant prévu initialement par le projet
de loi de finances pour 2015
c'est-à-dire avant le prélèvement de 2,5
millions d'euros de crédit hors titre 2
opérer à l'Assemblée nationale sur un de
vos amendements madame la ministre mais
le croyez vous mes chers collègues ceci
pour abonder le fond d'amorçage des
rythmes scolaires je vous remercie je
vous remercie ma chère collègue
je vous rappelle et il me semble pas
inutile de le rappeler que le temps de
parole attribué à chaque groupe pour
chaque discussion comprend le temps
d'intervention générale et celui de
l'explication de vote je vous rappelle
également qu'en application des
décisions de la conférence des
présidents aucune intervention des
orateurs des groupes de la dépasser 10
minutes par ailleurs le gouvernement
dispose au total de 20 minutes pour
intervenir la parole est à Madame
Christine Blandin pour 7 minutes
chez le président madame la ministre
chers collègues le premier budget de la
Nation en hausse traduit la priorité
donnée à l'éducation et met en oeuvre
les choix ambitieux qui ont été faits
lors de la loi de refondation de l'école
de la République je regrette que nous
rapporteurs pointe l'inflation
budgétaire eux qui ont appartenu à une
majorité qui a multiplié les réformes
parfois sans passer devant le Parlement
sans aucune évaluation supprimer des
postes à tours de bras cautionner la
catastrophique réforme de la
masterisation dont nous avons hérité
qu'elle essaie une école sinistrée
compromettant l'avenir de certains
enfants écoutez quand on fait de la
casse il y a des coûts de réparation et
quand on a une ambition comme notre loi
il y a un prix
il me semble utile de rappeler que la
mastérisation a eu pour conséquence
entre autres l'affectation de stagiaires
désemparée dans des établissements
relevant de l'éducation prioritaire ou
dans plusieurs établissements à la fois
parfois trois établissements
la majorité de ces enseignants
découvraient tardivement leur
affectation sur des créneaux horaire
dont on ne voulait pas les autres
professeurs ce constat c'est la Cour des
comptes qu'il adressait dans leur
rapport public de 2012 le redressement
en cours grâce à l'adoption de la loi de
refondation à laquelle le Sénat a porté
une contribution
significative a permis une véritable
amélioration en termes de poste et de
formation avec la mise en place des
espèces le plus de mettre que de classe
l'accueil des plus petits
l'accompagnement du handicap ou encore
le maintien de petites écoles rurales
qui n'en déplaisent à nos rapporteurs
cela nécessite des moyens financiers il
reste encore des tensions de terrain qui
appelle des efforts pour l'éducation
prioritaire le plus de maîtres que de
classe est indispensable pour dégager
des temps collectifs différenciés ou de
concertation pour ces raisons les
écologistes en accord avec ce budget en
augmentation de
2,4%. Madame la Ministre votre dernière
annonce le 21 novembre à Lens était le
plan d'action tous mobilisés contre le
décrochage scolaire doté de 50 millions
d'euros supplémentaires en hausse de 7 %
avec d'ici 2020 un objectif de 300
millions je me réjouis de ce plan
ambitieux afin qu'il donne un certain de
nos jeunes décrochés une nouvelle chance
de qualification mais la réussite de
l'école repose aussi madame la ministre
sur votre vigilance à ce que la richesse
de la loi de refondait sont de l'école
ne s'étiolent pas dans l'oubli des uns
ou la mauvaise volonté des autres
l'école inclusive et l'affaire de tous
nous attirons votre attention sur la
nécessité que le ministère veille à
l'application à la lettre et sur le
terrain de la loi de refondation en
régulier via les recettes les igen les
cadres des Gesco ce n'est pas parce que
l'Université Autonome qu'elle est
dispensée d'appliquer la loi je pense à
la rénovation des contenus de formation
pour faire toutes leurs places aux
enseignements transversaux directement
liés à la pratique professionnelle à la
pédagogie de la coopération la laïcité
la promotion de l'égalité la lutte
contre les discriminations ou encore la
prise en compte de la difficulté
scolaire dans les démarches
d'apprentissage je pense à la
participation dans les équipes des
formateurs d'une pluralité
d'intervenants extérieure
issue du terrain aussi bien des
enseignants en exercice que des acteurs
de l'éducation populaire ou des artistes
veillez à cela c'est respecter le
Parlement vous avez aussi annoncé le
plan numérique pour l'école quels en
sont moyen et quel sera l'accompagnement
le plus important pour vos dépenses
comme pour celles des collectivités
n'est-il pas que votre ministère apporte
de l'intelligence et des conseils à la
démarche d'équipement les séduisant de
tablettes saveurs de piètre outils
d'initiation à la programmation et des
modèles d'obsolescence programmés
certaines restaient non connectées dans
certains territoires de wifi de superbes
tableaux interactifs s'avère
incompatible avec des matériels achetés
par le biais d'un autre marché ou de
marcher successifs par les collectivités
enfin la présence d'équipements
fonctionnel ne sera utile qu'avec des
maîtres formés à cette révolution
pédagogique
un maître formateur écrivait
ce n'est pas parce que l'enseignant sait
se servir d'une tablette ou d'un
smartphone qu'il saura l'utiliser en
classe avec ses élèves et Serge Tisseron
alerter notre commission dans le groupe
média et nouvelle technologie en
expliquant puisque la relation au savoir
devient moins verticale et plus
horizontale il faut favoriser le travail
en groupe organisé l'alternance entre
travail individuel et en groupe et pour
cela évitez d'associer chaque enfant à
un écran il faut au contraire encourager
les enfants à travailler trois ou quatre
ensemble face à un seul écran car la
culture des écrans c'est apprendre à
travailler avec d'autres
toutes ces responsabilités elles sont
auprès de votre ministère elle ne coûte
rien mais il faut diffuser
l'intelligence partout pour terminer les
écologistes considèrent la volonté de
conditionner le fondamental de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires à la
réalisation d'un peu d'été comme un
excellent signe
enfin il m'est impossible de ne pas
évoquer l'enseignement agricole nous
pensions que notre rapporteur madame
Ferrat a les baigner dans le bonheur et
décréter un avis super favorable à ce
budget en augmentation malheureusement
le budget en hausse ne l'a pas séduite
nous ne nous félicitons particulièrement
des démarches prospectives qui sont
menées dans certaines régions afin
d'identifier les besoins à venir dans
certains métiers la souplesse
d'adaptation et l'intelligence
pédagogique de certains établissements
agricoles permettent de dissiper la
vision obsolète d'une brésilien réservé
aux élèves en échec les succès qu'on y
rencontre devrait inspirer plus
d'ouverture aux innovations pédagogiques
dans les écoles madame la ministre ce
budget ambitieux tel que vous l'avez
présenté nous le votons si par malheur
les amendements destructeurs des
rapporteurs étaient adoptés nous le
refuserions merci ma chère collègue la
parole est à Madame Françoise Laborde
pour 8 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues l'école se trouve
dans une situation de crise majeure 20%
des élèves de 15 ans ne maîtrise pas les
connaissances de base en mathématiques
et en français et 150000 élèves sont
abandonnés chaque année en situation
d'échec
s'ajoute à cela comme en atteste le
dernier rapport pyza que loin de
parvenir à réduire les inégalités
sociales le système éducatif français
les accentuent aussi la réussite
scolaire des élèves n'a jamais été aussi
étroitement corrélé à leur origine
sociale quelle triste des aveux pour
l'école de la République qui se veut à
l'origine être un facteur d'émancipation
et d'ascension sociale
tel est le bilan de 10 années de
politique de casse des services publics
donc celui de l'éducation nationale
sacrifiée sur l'hôtel de la soi-disant
rationalisation de l'action publique
défendue par l'ancienne majorité
la qualité de notre service public
d'éducation et pourtant déterminante
pour donner à notre pays la capacité les
moyens de relever les défis de la lutte
contre le chômage notamment chez les
jeunes la réduction des inégalités
sociales la restauration de la cohésion
nationale au travers de l'apprentissage
de la citoyenneté et des valeurs de la
République
dès 2012 le gouvernement s'est attaché à
redonner durablement à l'école les
moyens de remplir sa mission et madame
la ministre nous constatons avec
satisfaction que pour la troisième année
consécutive la priorité donnée à
l'enseignement scolaire se traduit dans
la politique budgétaire du gouvernement
la progression d'environ 2% des crédits
de la mission enseignement scolaire les
portant ainsi à 64,9 milliards d'euros
en autorisation d'engagement et 65 02
milliards en crédit de paiement ainsi
que l'augmentation des moyens humains
qui lui sont affectés attestent que la
volonté du gouvernement et je le salue
de se donner les moyens de mener une
politique éducative ambitieuse
dans le temps est parti je vais
m'intéresser à trois points et tout
d'abord la formation des enseignants
conformément à l'objectif des 60 000
créations de postes dans l'Éducation
nationale sur le quinquennat le projet
de loi de finance pour 2015 prévoit 9421
poste supplémentaires dont
5334 d'enseignant l'amélioration de
l'encadrement des élèves est une
condition essentielle pour refonder une
école permettant la réussite de tous
pour autant et sans surprise l'actuel
majorité sénatoriale y est opposé
d'ailleurs étire
utile de rappeler que sous le précédent
quinquennat cette même majorité avait
supprimé pas moins de 80 000 postes dans
l'Éducation nationale
par ailleurs au détriment de la réussite
scolaire des élèves la formation
professionnelle des enseignants avait
été purement et simplement supprimé là
encore sous couvert d'économie alors que
les dépenses d'éducation dépensent
d'avenir s'accroisent partout dans le
monde la loi pour la refondation de
l'école de juillet 2013 et heureusement
revenu sur cette aberration en créant
les écoles supérieures et de l'éducation
celle-ci assure une formation initiale
et continue de qualité pour les
personnels de l'enseignement et de
l'éducation qui comprennent aussi bien
des enseignements théoriques et
pratiques que l'acquisition des
compétences professionnelles en
particulier au travers de stage et de
l'intervention de professionnels
exerçant dans le milieu scolaire et
éducatif un autre point important de la
réussite éducative et qui me tient à
cœur l'orientation la loi pour la
refondation de l'école a également été
l'occasion de repenser notre système
d'éducation et d'orientation afin de
favoriser les parcours choisis et
construits il est en effet primordial
que chaque élève puisse voir proposer et
ce à chaque étape de sa scolarité dès
son plus jeune âge un parcours
individuel d'information d'orientation
et de découverte du monde professionnel
aujourd'hui en fin de troisième 65% des
élèves sont envoyés en seconde générale
et technologique et 32% en seconde
professionnelle ou cap de plus les
décisions d'orientation ne sont pas à
l'abri des inégalités sociales lorsque
89% des enfants de cadres sont orientés
en seconde générale et technologie seul
36% des enfants d'inactifs et 43% des
employés de service le sont aussi nous
nous félicitons qu'avec la mise en place
du service public régional de
l'orientation par la loi du 5 mars 2014
relative à la formation professionnelle
à l'emploi et à la démocratie sociale
l'orientation des élèves est devenue une
politique à part entière
enseignant conseiller d'orientation et
familles seront désormais pleinement
associés pour accompagner l'élève dans
ses choix d'avenir
enfin mon dernier point et je sais
madame la ministre que vous l'attendiez
c'est la morale laïque la République
française est construite autour de son
école et par son école c'est pourquoi le
président François Hollande veut je cite
refonder l'école de la République pour
refonder la République par l'école
madame la ministre a une semaine de la
journée nationale de la laïcité je
souhaite vous interroger sur un sujet
auquel les radicaux de gauche sont
particulièrement attachés je le sais en
2012 minceur Peillon alors ministre de
l'éducation nationale avait annoncé
qu'il souhaitait mettre en place un
enseignement de la morale laïque qui
serait dispensé dès le primaire et ce
jusqu'au lycée en juillet dernier le
Conseil supérieur des programmes
présenté ses propositions sur ce qui est
devenu l'enseignement moral et civique
cet enseignement constituera une matière
à part entière qui sera dispensée à
raison d'une heure par semaine de
l'école au lycée et évaluer dès la
rentrée 2015 or madame la ministre je
regrette que sur les 7 points développés
dans le programme le terme laïque
n'apparaisse qu'une seule fois aussi je
vous remercie de bien vouloir nous
donner des précisions sur les origines
d'un tel changement d'orientation et sur
la manière dont vous comptez pour suivre
l'action vous comprendrez mon inquiétude
comment gérer l'enseignement religieux
en Alsace Moselle avec l'enseignement
moral et civique mon choix est fait et
j'espère que ce sera le vôtre de même
l'enseignement du fait religieux dont
parle un certain rapport sénatorial
récents que j'ai un peu de mal à digérer
devrait être vu avec attention et en
intégrant ce qui doit être dit ou après
dans l'enseignement moral et civique
notre école publique doit rester laïque
garante des valeurs de la République et
protégeant tous les enfants quel que
soit leur origine et leur religion
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
le groupe RDSE constate avec
satisfaction que le gouvernement malgré
un contexte budgétaire contraint
mobilise les moyens financiers et
humains nécessaires à faire de l'école
de la République un puissant moyen
d'émancipation sociale et
d'apprentissage du vivre ensemble c'est
pourquoi nous voterons les crédits de
cette mission sous les mêmes réserves
que ma collègue
Marie-Christine Blandet en espérant que
les amendements ne changeront pas le
fond de cette mission je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Jacques Bernard manier pour 7
minutes moi j'ai un collègue
c'est le président de madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
l'école c'est une grande institution qui
a toujours tenu une place particulière
tant dans l'histoire de notre République
que dans notre propre construction
personnelle
l'émission de l'école sont essentielles
la transmission des connaissances le
partage des valeurs de la République
l'exercice de la citoyenneté
l'apprentissage et le respect des règles
communes le savoir l'autonomie
l'initiative l'engagement sont autant
d'exemples de ce fait le projet de
budget de l'enseignement scolaire que
nous examinons aujourd'hui et d'une
importance capitale
cependant ce budget est porteur d'une
double ambition la première est de
remettre l'école de la République à la
place qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû quitter
en tête des priorités budgétaires de
notre pays
puisque cette année nous avons le
plaisir de voter les budgets d'émission
au Sénat au nom des sénatrices et des
sénateurs socialistes je souhaite
exprimer notre satisfaction de voir
l'éducation nationale redevenir le
premier poste de dépenses de ce pays
pour nos écoles il faut le répéter
la hausse des crédits de 2,4% par
rapport à 2014 se traduira entre autres
par la création de plus de 10400 postes
soit de nombreux enseignants au service
de la réussite de nos élèves et c'est
bien là un point de débat majeur entre
nous nous pensons qu'il est nécessaire
d'avoir des enseignants devant les
élèves contrairement à vous chers
collègues
il serait simpliste de résumer les
efforts budgétaires à la seule
augmentation du nombre d'enseignants
devant nos jeunes cette augmentation du
budget permet aussi de répondre à une
seconde ambition faire de la loi de
refondation de l'école que nous avons
votée ici même souvenez majoritairement
mes chers collègues une réalité dans les
établissements scolaires de notre pays
ces crédits que nous voterons bien
entendu avec les mêmes réserves qui ont
été exprimées pour ce qui nous concerne
le groupe socialiste car ils seront voté
mes chers collègues à la fin du parcours
budgétaire malgré les oppositions et les
mauvaises raisons qui ne sont que des
postures politiciennes dans notre école
publique pourrait bien se passer
aujourd'hui ces crédits donc permettront
aussi de poursuivre la réforme de la
formation initiale des enseignants via
des nouvelles écoles supérieures du
professorat et d'éducation et continuer
de donner la priorité au premier degré
en ce sens je me permets d'illustrer mon
propos en insistant sur l'évolution
constatée en matière de création des
postes de titulaire le nombre de postes
ouverts par session de concours de
professeurs des écoles dans le second
degré passe de 10932 en 2013 à 12919 en
2015 c'est-à-dire une hausse effective
de plus de 15%. dans le même temps les
concours dans le premier degré ouvrent
1728 postes pour la session en 2015 au
lieu en lieu et place des 8413 postes en
2013 ce qui signifie un renforcement des
effectifs de plus de
28%. par ailleurs des inscriptions des
étudiants sont à la hausse en le
constate dans tous les secteurs pour ces
concours qui sont désormais en
adéquation avec les besoins marqués un
peu partout dans notre pays dans le
premier degré le nombre d'étudiants
inscrit aux divers concours à progresser
de 72% entre 2013 et 2015 et nous
constatons une augmentation particulière
dans les académies où les besoins sont
les plus forts comme dans l'académie de
Créteil souvent prise en exemple à cette
tribune avec 1000 candidats
supplémentaires en 2015
dans le second degré les inscriptions au
concours ont progressé de 16,5% entre
2013 et 2015 remarqueront là encore un
fort accroissement dans les disciplines
dit déficitaires souvenez-vous mes chers
collègues on ne le trouve plus de
professeur notamment pour les
mathématiques et bien les mathématiques
enregistrent une hausse de près de 50%
d'inscription au concours ces chiffres
très encourageants démontrent que la
politique ambitieuse portait par le
gouvernement pour l'éducation nationale
doublée de la modernisation des métiers
de l'enseignement et remarquablement
comprise et soutenu par les étudiants
enfin ce métier est en train de
retrouver l'attractivité qu'il avait
autrefois et qu'il avait perdu
malheureusement dans les dernières
années
ce budget comporte aussi des assurances
budgétaires pour l'accompagnement des
rythmes scolaires il y a quelques
semaines j'avais avec d'autres attiré
votre attention madame la ministre ainsi
que celle de Monsieur le Ministre du
Budget sur l'inquiétude des maires de
France quant au devenir du fonds
d'amorçage consacré à la réforme des
rythmes scolaires
effectivement une de nos premiers
préoccupations était que la réforme des
rythmes scolaires soit pérennisé et que
ça réussite se confirme à cet effet il
fallait accompagné les communes et pas
seulement celle qui bénéficie de la
dotation de solitude urbaine cible de la
dotation rurale cible ou appartenante à
des départements d'outre-mer il fallait
accompagner toutes les communes toutes
les communes qui ont la chance et
j'espère que ça reste une fierté
aujourd'hui encore d'avoir une ou
plusieurs écoles sur son territoire pour
les communes toutes ces communes étaient
sont désormais seront désormais
concernés par le soutien de l'État ainsi
les députés du groupe SRC à l'Assemblée
nationale on déposé un amendement visant
à rétablir le bénéfice de l'aide
forfaitaire de base à l'ensemble des
communes tout en le conditionnant à
l'établissement d'un projet éducatif
terristorial ce qui est bien le moins
pour structurer ces fameuses activités
qui aujourd'hui se déroulent dans nos
22000 communes de France qui ont une
école ou plusieurs
nous nous félicitons de cette de
l'adoption de cet amendement avec le
soutien du gouvernement nous le voterons
ici aussi bien entendu madame la
ministre
Asie je voudrais vous faire part d'une
double satisfaction d'une part celle
pour les parlementaires d'avoir été
entendus malgré les dires de
l'opposition au sujet du soutien aux
communes pour la mise en place de cet
accueil périscolaire et d'autre part
celle de voir notre engagement confirmé
de vouloir redonner à notre école les
moyens de remplir ces missions au
service de la jeunesse mission qui ont
été réaffirmés renforcés dans la loi de
refondation de l'école de la République
enfin je conclurai mon propos avec ces
quelques mots empruntés à Abraham
Lincoln qui s'exprimait devant les
sceptiques de son temps en ces termes
qui n'ont rien perdu de leur force ni de
leur réalisme si vous trouvez que
l'éducation coûte cher essayez
l'ignorance je vous remercie merci
la parole est à Madame Brigitte Gontier
Morin pour 9 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ce projet de loi de
finances 2015 ah je ne vous le cache pas
un goût amer pour au moins deux raisons
cette année plus aucun rapport
budgétaire n'est spécifiquement consacré
à l'enseignement professionnel une
première depuis 15 ans cette décision
prise après le renouvellement sénatorial
par la nouvelle majorité umpudie est un
symbole qui en dit long sur les
objectifs oubliés de ceux qui
prétendaient il y a sept ans vouloir
valoriser revaloriser la filière
professionnelle pas un mot sur cette
filière qui en 2013
représentait 27% des bacheliers français
alors même que s'annonçait cette année
pour eux l'épreuve de vérité en termes
de poursuite d'études un des objectifs
affichés par les promoteurs de la
réforme du bac pro en 3 ans et que les
nouveaux pouvoirs des régions sur la
carte des formations aurait
limiter notre expertise je tenais à le
dire en préambule pour continuer à
défendre cet enseignement pour lequel
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être rapporteur pour
avis pour notre commission s'est
endurant au gré des changements de
président la deuxième raison concerne la
crise de recrutement des enseignants une
crise du Vivier qui persiste je souhaite
ainsi poursuivre le dialogue que nous
avons ébauché sur ce sujet madame la
ministre il y a trois semaines lors de
ma question d'actualité aujourd'hui
l'UMP par la voie de son rapporteur
spécial monsieur Longuet dénonce au
travers des créations de postes
inscrites ce budget dans ce budget une
politique du chiffre un compte pour ceux
qui pendant cinq années ont mené la pire
politique du chiffre avec la suppression
de 80000 postes à l'éducation nationale
l'amendement que Monsieur Longuet
défendra au nom de la commission des
finances vise à revenir sur les
créations de postes de stagiaires et à
le nombre de remplacements dans le
second degré en minorant de 160 millions
d'euros les crédits de l'admission pour
2015 un mauvais remake de la période
d'Archos Châtel pourtant la crise de
recrutement est aujourd'hui
incontestable en 2013
10959 et PT inscrits en loi de finances
n'avait pas été consommé deux raisons
principales recoupant le diagnostic que
j'avais établi dès 2011 à l'issue des
travaux de la mission d'information sur
le métier d'enseignant le concours de
recrutement les concours de recrutement
ne font pas le plein tout comme les
postes de stagiaires et de contractuels
quand on nombre de sorties il a été en
2013 plus important que prévu sauf pour
les départs en retraite puis faites
attendues le premier degré que certains
pensaient à l'abri connaît aussi des
problèmes pour recruter et si l'académie
de Créteil est particulièrement touchée
n'est pas la seule
des petites annonces de Pôle emploi en
atteste la politique de recrutement qui
est remise en place depuis 2012 était
donc absolument nécessaire et
indispensable ce qui fait des banques
entre nous à gauche c'est l'ampleur de
la crise ces raisons et les moyens d'y
remédier sur l'ampleur des besoins le
gouvernement s'est fixé pour objectif de
créer 54000 postes à l'éducation
nationale lors des travaux de la mission
d'information précitées face à la crise
de recrutement que nous avions identifié
et aux besoins de démocratisation de
notre système éducatif j'avais chiffré
les recrutements
départs en retraite compris à 150 000
sur 50 sur les raisons de la crise la
lecture de l'édition 2014 de France
portrait social de l'Insee confirme que
les effectifs d'enseignants dans le
second degré sont en baisse depuis 2004
Lindsay monte que de 2003 à 2007 les
effectifs d'élèves et d'enseignants ont
diminué conjointement à partir de 2007
le nombre d'élèves s'est stabilisé il
réaugmente même à partir de 2011 tandis
que le nombre d'enseignants lui
continuer de diminuer globalement il y
avait en 2013 11% d'enseignants en moins
qu'en 2000 pour seulement 4% d'élèves en
moins la crise de recrutement notamment
dans le second degré et donc antérieur à
2007 elle a été amplifiée accélérée par
la RGPP et la masse stérilisation à
l'éducation nationale la RGPP s'est
traduite par moins de postes ouverts au
concours qui ne compensent plus que la
moitié des départs en retraite
particulièrement important en 2011 à ce
phénomène se sont ajoutés les effets de
la masterialisation à partir de 2011 il
faut avoir validé ou au moins être
inscrit en master pour s'inscrire au
concours quand précédemment le de
nombreux candidats n'étaient titulaires
que d'une licence ce changement entre né
des réorientations comme le souligné
c'est certains candidats n'ont pas
souhaité ou pas eu les moyens de
poursuivre voire de reprendre leurs
études jusqu'au Master
lui reporter leurs candidature de
quelques années le temps d'obtenir leur
diplôme une fois celui-ci obtenu leur
perspective professionnelle se sont
élargies et certains ont choisi un autre
métier et c'est notamment le cas des
maths c'est pourquoi je propose toujours
d'agir simultanément sur deux leviers le
premier la mise en place d'une formation
alimentée par de véritables pré
recrutements où les étudiants ne sont
pas utilisés comme des moyens
d'enseignement en responsabilité
d'élèves dès la première année de Master
car former des enseignants demande du
temps de leur donner les moyens
matériels financiers de Me tener leurs
études et de réussir le concours car le
nombre d'inscrits j'insiste nous l'avons
vu depuis 10 ans ne fait pas le nombre
de reçu une question fondamentale me
semble ignorer de quel enseignement
enseignant avons-nous besoin notre
société de plus en plus structurée par
des savoirs complexes des savoirs
savants qui modèlent les situations
auxquelles sont remonter les citoyens
les travailleurs cette évolution pose
donc à notre société et à fortiori à
l'école un défi d'élévation du niveau de
connaissance il ne s'agit plus
d'apprendre par cœur de restituer à
savoir mais de comprendre de substituer
de mettre en relation des savoirs une
exigence de réflexion qui se conjuguent
avec des contenus devenus plus
notionnels nous soutenions donc l'idée
de refondation de l'école principe qui
selon nous devrait irriguer davantage la
réforme de la formation des enseignants
il faut aussi donner aux enseignants les
moyens de faire évoluer leurs pratiques
pour assurer la réussite de tous les
élèves ce qui implique une formation de
haut niveau construite dans un continuum
conjuguant discipline professionnelle
dans un système d'aller-retour en lien
avec la recherche avec une entrée dans
le métier progressive allant du stage
d'observation au stage en
responsabilités la relance du processus
de démocratisation de notre système
scolaire appuyé sur le principe que tous
les élèves sont capables d'apprendre
implique cette exigence dans la
formation des enseignants second levier
instauré un plan plus réel de
recrutement par degré et par discipline
ce qui implique d'affiner les prévisions
sur les départs en retraite et sur les
effectifs des lèvres
l'existence d'un tel plan permettrait de
donner de la visibilité aux étudiants
souhaitant s'engager dans le métier
sortir de la gestion de l'urgence à
chaque rentrée et faire refuer les
inégalités qui règnent d'une académie à
l'autre pour pallier le monde
d'enseignants titulaire et aussi sortir
de l'urgence comme nous l'avons connu il
y a quelques jours encore à l'académie
de Créteil un concours supplémentaire
pourquoi pas s'il s'agit de rattraper
les bons candidats de toute la France
c'est ce qui avait été fait en 2013 avec
les deux concours mais pourquoi le
limiter à la seule académie de Créteil à
500 postes un nouveau parcours alternant
en deux ans les étudiants seraient en
responsabilité d'élèves payés à payer un
SMIC en ma et en même en M2 ce parcours
serait articulé avec un concours
spécifique en fin de M1 qui validerait
leurs acquis professionnels deux aspects
m'inquiètent nous demeurons dans un
système qui persiste à placer les
étudiants immédiatement responsabilité
de classe quid de leur master du lien à
la recherche du temps pour un retour sur
leur pratique nous sommes encore donc
très loin des ambitions auxquelles
j'aspire deuxièmement l'ouverture d'une
brèche dans le principe national du
concours fondement du statut de la
fonction publique autant de raisons
diamétralement opposé à ceux de mes
collègues de l'UMP et de l'udié qui fera
que mon groupe n'adoptera pas les
crédits de cette mission a fortiori si
l'amendement de Monsieur Longuet est
adopté merci ma chère collègue la parole
est à Monsieur cl Aude Kern
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les orateurs qui
m'ont précédé le rappelait avec force
nous examinons ici un budget important
celui de la mission éducative de l'État
qui doit répondre à notre ambition
partagée de réussite de tous les enfants
de la République avec budget 2015 en
hausse malgré le contact contexte
général de baisse des dépenses
l'enseignement scolaire redevient le
premier poste de dépense de la nation
en tant qu'enseignant de formation et de
profession je ne peux que me réjouir de
cette marque d'un engagement politique
cependant au-delà de ce classement je
crois que nous devons nous poser les
bonnes questions celle des enjeux qui
sous tendent cette volonté pour le
politique et celle des perspectives
qu'elle dessine les enjeux quels
sont-ils nous connaissons tous les
classifications internationales qui sont
particulièrement cruelles à l'endroit du
système scolaire français ainsi les
tests du PISA ne place la France qu'au
18e rang de l'ensemble des pays de
l'OCDE un positionnement en régression
continue année après année et alors même
que la dépense éducative ne cesse
d'augmenter
et nul besoin de classement
internationaux
grâce aux examens de la journée défense
et citoyenneté nous apprenons chaque
année qu'environ 20% de nos adolescents
ne maîtrisent pas les compétences du
socle en matière de lecture
malheureusement le constat d'échec ne
s'arrête pas là les évaluations au sein
de l'OCDE révèle également que la France
et la championne des inégalités
scolaires au lieu de corriger les
déterminismes géographiques ou sociaux
notre école de la République les
renforce face à cette situation
préoccupante madame la ministre que nous
proposez-vous essentiellement une
réponse quantitative notamment avec la
création de 9561 postes supplémentaires
en 2015 qui représentera un coup estimé
à 125 millions d'euros dès 2015 et 250
millions en 2016 ne le n'y en pas mes
chers collègues le nombre d'enseignants
est nécessairement l'un des facteurs de
réussite de nos élèves
cependant faut-il en faire la réponse
unique à tous les mots de notre système
éducatif
le rapport de la Cour des comptes
intitulé gérer les enseignements
autrement démontrent très clairement que
notre système éducatif est déficient et
que ni les réductions d'effectifs ni les
créations de poste ne peuvent constituer
une réponse appropriée
autrement dit tant qu'aucune véritable
réforme qualitative et de profondeur ne
sera engagée les efforts budgétaires qui
sont aussi ceux des français resteront
inefficaces et inefficient
bien avant les moyens notre système
éducatif exige une gestion plus ajustée
plus affinée plus pertinente des
personnel éducatifs ainsi qu'une prise
abrahal corps des problèmes structurels
de notre école et ils sont nombreux ces
problèmes auxquels la grande loi sur la
Redon refondation de l'école n'a pas
répondu et auquel ce budget 2015
n'apporte pas davantage de réponse j'en
citerai ici quelques-uns tout d'abord un
constat déjà évoqué par mes collègues le
métier d'enseignement d'enseignants est
insuffisamment attractif les enseignants
français sont moins payés payés que ceux
des autres pays cela est très marqué
dans le primaire où l'écart entre la
rémunération des enseignants français et
celle des voisins et de plus de 16%
cet écart doit d'autant plus nous
interroger que les études démontrent que
les systèmes performants sont aussi ceux
qui offrent des salaires élevés à leurs
enseignants et forces et de constater
que la vocation ne suffit pas outre la
problématique de la rémunération il
reste à améliorer les conditions de
travail ou encore le regard de la
société sur la profession car les
enseignants français sont en mal d'amour
disons-le par ailleurs et notre
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
la culture Jean-Claude Karl l'a très
bien exprimé en rappelant
l'importance de l'effet maître or à quoi
sert-il d'ouvrir des postes si on ne
peut les pourvoir avec des candidats de
qualité madame la ministre il ne s'agit
pas seulement d'un problème de formation
une vraie revalorisation s'impose à la
fois sur les plans financiers et
sociétales
autre problème structurel de notre école
de la République la dévalorisation
généralisée des filières technologiques
ou professionnels qui limite fortement
le développement de l'enseignement
professionnel et de l'apprentissage il
faut en finir avec cette vision
archaïque et dépassée de la
professionnalisation systématiquement
dénigrée ces filières ne sont en aucun
on n'en aucune façon des voies de garage
qui seraient réservées au cancre de plus
en plus de voix s'élèvent contre ce
modèle de la scolarité qui privilégie la
voie prétendue royale de l'enseignement
général
cependant cette représentation véhiculée
par notre société à l'origine de la
désaffection des activités manuelles à
gangrené le système lui-même aujourd'hui
l'orientation toujours plus tardive des
élèves pour les maintenir dans la voie
générale induit une spécialisation
elle-même plus tardive tardive au
détriment de l'élève de l'entreprise en
tant que frontalier je ne résiste pas
l'envie d'évoquer ici le système de
formation professionnelle de nos voisins
allemands en Allemagne et la formation
professionnelle initiale est organisée
principalement sous forme
d'apprentissage appelé système dual
puisqu'elle se déroule sur deux lieux de
formation l'entreprise et l'école
professionnelle dans ce système qui a
fait ses preuves en termes de
qualification d'insertion des jeunes le
contenu de la formation relève d'Hélène
d'air et des partenaires économiques et
sociaux par ailleurs pour avoir moi-même
exercé parallèlement dans un lycée
technique et en entreprise je sais que
les acteurs économiques sont désireux de
prendre une vraie place dans les
dispositifs d'orientation et de
développement des formations
professionnelles nombreux sont les chefs
d'entreprise dont la maison mère est
allemande à m'interpeller sur le sujet
en rappelant tout le bien qu'il pense de
nos formations techniques antérieures à
la à la dernière réforme du lycée alors
madame la ministre pourquoi vouloir
éloigner nos élèves du monde de
l'entreprise qu'attendez-vous pour
ouvrir davantage notre école à
l'entreprise il est urgent de faire
bouger les lignes sur ce sur le sujet
nous devons créer des pôles d'excellence
qui regrouperait des filières entières
dans des lycées technologiques ou
professionnels jusqu'au BTS voir
jusqu'au niveau bac +3 ayant de
l'ambition pour nos enfants créés on de
vrais lycées des métiers pourtant je ne
crois pas que vous manquez d'ambition
pour notre école de la République madame
la ministre car il y a de bonnes
orientations dans la loi de sur la
refondation de l'école et dans ce budget
reconnaissons le tout de même mes chers
collègues
je pourrais soulever ici d'autres sujets
d'interrogations notamment celui du
statut des directeurs d'écolos ou encore
du taux de remplacement en baisse
constante mais le temps risquerait de me
manquer je n'évoque pas non plus les
crédits de l'enseignement agricole
brillamment rapporté pour avis par notre
collègue Françoise Ferrat qui portent
très clairement la voix du groupe
udi UC sur ce sujet messieurs les
rapporteurs je ne vous oublie pas et je
salue également la qualité de vos
travaux bien entendu mais je veux
terminer mon intervention par une
question qui est préoccupe tous les élus
mais aussi les parents et qui ne vous
surprendra pas Madame la Ministre la
question de rythme scolaire dans sa
version initiale l'article 55 du projet
de loi de finance pour 2015 prévoyez une
prorogation du fondamorçage pour la
seule année scolaire 2015-2016
depuis la présentation du projet de loi
la mobilisation des élus apporter ses
fruits puisque le Premier ministre a
annoncé à l'occasion du congrès des
maires la semaine dernière la
pérennisation de cette aide c'est une
bonne nouvelle et je tiens à saluer le
pas que vous avez bien voulu faire
madame la ministre cependant deux
problèmes majeurs restent irrésolus à
mon sens le premier est lié à la
conditionnalité de l'aide soumise à
l'élaboration d'un projet éducatif
territorial si votre souci est
compréhensible madame la ministre
avez-vous pensé à ses nombreuses
communes rurales qui n'ont ni les moyens
humains ni les moyens matériels
d'élaborer un tel document
quel soutien pourront-elle attendre de
la part de l'État et ce n'est pas une
légende le second problème est lié au
coup de mise en place des rythmes
scolaires bien supérieurs à l'aide
consenti par l'État dans un contexte de
baisse des dotations
tous les élus locaux qui se contraignent
déjà des efforts importants
s'interrogent sur la capacité à
maintenir des services publics de
proximité de qualité aujourd'hui de
nombreuses communes sont confrontées à
de graves problèmes de financement du
fait de la faiblesse de la contribution
de l'État au regard des véritables
coûts de la réforme il s'agit là d'un
véritable transfert de charges sans
juste contre partie financière qui
risque par ailleurs de provoquer une
prise en charge éducative à deux
vitesses les enfants des communes les
plus riches pouvant bénéficier d'un
meilleur accompagnement que ceux des
communes des plus fragiles madame la
ministre l'État se doit d'assurer
l'égalité d'accès à l'éducation c'est la
responsabilité de l'État et du
gouvernement j'en termine
d'assumer l'intégralité des surcoûts
liés à la mise en œuvre des rythmes
scolaires
dans l'attente de la mise en oeuvre
d'une politique en ce sens le groupe udi
UC votre a les crédits de la mission
enseignement scolaire et l'article 55 du
projet de loi des finances sous réserve
de l'adoption des amendements proposés
par les rapporteurs pour avis je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jacques Grosperrin
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
lorsqu'on est lorsqu'on examine la
politique budgétaire conduite par
l'actuel majorité on ne peut que
constater que les années passent les
problèmes demeure et les mauvaises
solutions se maintiennent
la mission anciennement scolaire
représente dans le présent projet de
budget
66,4 milliards d'euros c'est le premier
budget de l'État et ne cesse de croître
pourtant c'est un sévère constat qui
doit être dressé l'école de la
République n'atteint plus ses objectifs
elle peine à compenser les inégalités
sociales les territoriales et l'échoue
littéralement dans la lutte contre le
décrochage 130 à 150 000 élèves à ce
jour décrocheurs dans notre système la
question qu'on devrait se poser ça
serait peut-être plus faire en sorte de
réfléchir sur le fait qu'il ne décroche
pas et non pas simplement mettre un
futur plan de repérage certainement
intéressant mais pas simplement
suffisant 40% des élèves sont en
difficulté on sait qu'à ce jour à
l'entrée en 6ème 40% des élèves ne
maîtrisent pas les fonctions
fondamentales en tout cas les savoirs
fondamentaux que l'école doit leur
donner le redoublement est encore trop
important
même s'il y a une réflexion très forte
vis-à-vis des redoublement peut
s'interroger aussi sur cet effet on sait
très bien que redoubler ne permet pas
toujours de mieux réussir comment
inverser la tendance comment le
gouvernement tant t-il remédier à
l'abaissement constant du niveau des
élèves comment espère-t-il retrouver ce
formidable à son sur social qui était
l'école de la République j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure souvent des propos après
la plus beau temps c'était la Comtesse
de Ségur j'ai l'impression que rien n'a
été faux auparavant et que désormais
nous sommes dans un jour nouveau tout
fonctionne bien les crédits sont là les
résultats sont là or ce n'est pas ça
votre seule réponse à ce jour c'est par
l'augmentation du nombre d'enseignants
véritable totem auquel s'accroche une
majorité peut-être en manque
d'imagination de perspective et aussi
peut-être du courage politique
on sait qu'à ce jour il y a un calcul a
été fait vous voulez créer plus
d'enseignants pourquoi pas plus
enseignants si on savait si le
fonctionnement de plus enseignant ou le
fait de mettre plus enseignants
permettait de mieux réussir l'école nous
serions d'accord avec vous certains ont
calculé qu'on augmentant en augmentant
il faudra peut-être du courage en
augmentant et c'est une question de deux
heures le volume horaire en tout cas des
enseignants par semaine ça permettrait
la création de 45000 postes sans
augmentation financière impactant le
budget qu'on en juge
93% du budget de la somme considérable
de ces 66,4 milliards d'euros sont
affectés aux dépenses de personnel elles
absorbent donc la quasi intégralité du
budget mais comme je disais votre
gouvernement souhaite encore plus
enseignant on se souvient de cette
promesse tous de Messieurs Hollande et
payons dans la boucher 60000 cette année
ce sont 9421 postes équivalent en plein
qui seront ainsi créés en exécution de
l'objectif de création des 54000 postes
fixés par la loi du 8 juillet 2013 la
logique qui est à l'oeuvre et celle de
toujours plus toujours plus de moyens
toujours plus enseignants alors que
l'Europe nous surveille sur nos dépenses
si l'accroissement des moyens humains et
la bonne solution je ne pourrais nous ne
pourrions qu'applaudir et vous suivre
dans cette démarche malheureusement
cette logique ne fonctionne pas année
par année les études PISA et NAEP la
Cour des comptes nous montre nous prouve
et nous constate nous permet de
constater avec des effets dommageables
que la dégradation de la qualité du
système éducatif français est la piètre
efficacité de notre politique éducative
que l'on peut partager que l'on peut
comprendre que l'on peut comprendre
depuis de nombreuses années avec
quelques difficultés dans dont nous
avons une
nous avons une responsabilité parfois
partagée or nous savons très bien
et il y a un cabinet le cabinet McKinsey
qui montre que ce n'est pas de mettre
plus enseignant qui permettra d'avoir
des meilleurs résultats mais c'est de
s'interroger sur d'autres facteurs c'est
de faire en sorte que recruter les
meilleures enseignants recruter les
meilleures étudiants pour faire de bons
enseignants faudra peut-être les payer
un peu plus on avait fait on a bien
favorisé avec Luc Châtel à une certaine
époque en 2011 une augmentation dans
l'entrée du métier c'est aussi
s'interroger sur ce qui se passe dans la
classe mais c'est vrai que c'est le
sacro-saint domaine pédagogique des
enseignants sur lesquels on ne peut pas
aller et c'est vrai que c'est parfois
difficile de le faire on peut
s'interroger aussi sur le renforcement
des méthodes sur le terrain et réfléchir
sur un autre mode de concours il a il
est vrai qu'il est intéressant de faire
un concours très académique mais
réfléchir sur un concours peut-être plus
professionnel pour faire en sorte qu'il
ait plus de relations d'enseignants
entre eux dans ces transmissions des
savoirs des savoirs entre saignant sur
le terrain
ne pourrait-on pas commencer par
supprimer l'inégalité de traitement dans
son victime les enseignants du primaire
il gagne en moyenne 600 euros de moins
que les professeurs de lycée et leur
salaire sont nettement inférieur à leur
collègues des autres pays de l'OCDE or
nous savons fort bien le rôle est
essentiel ce n'est pas pour rien qu'ils
étaient autrefois nommés instituteurs et
institutrices ils instituent en effet
l'élève et le citoyen c'est une fonction
primordiale et il est impératif qu'elle
attire qu'elle attire les meilleurs une
revalorisation salariale madame la
ministre s'impose si l'on veut
encourager les talents et les vocation à
s'investir dans cette tâche essentielle
une réflexion aussi intéressante c'est
le statut de véritable directeur d'école
je pense qu'il faut qu'il y a un statut
juridique parce qu'on ne pourra pas
continuer longtemps à fonctionner ainsi
ne pas mettre en place un EPE c'est
quelque chose qui est grave qui ne
permettait qui ne permet pas d'avoir une
autorité hiérarchique il y aurait
directeur sur ses enseignants
nous l'avions fait je vous l'ai dit on
peut s'interroger sur le paiement des
néo titulaires on peut s'interroger sur
les recrutements où on peine ou nous
avons ou le ministère a vraiment
beaucoup de difficultés enfin la crise
de l'école
osons l'affirmer le révélateur d'une
crise d'une société déboussolée en perte
de repères dans ce contexte alors que
les colles et la communauté éducative
ont besoin de stabilité de sérénité vous
semblez tout mettre en oeuvre pour créer
des tensions provoquer des pertes de
temps et compromettent ainsi les
conditions d'accomplissement des
missions de l'école je ne reviendrai pas
trop longuement sur le formidable gâchis
qu'a représenter la mise en place des
nouveaux rythme scolaire décidé par un
décret sous forme peut-être trop
abribute arbitré en tout cas brutal sans
concertation et apposer sans
anticipation
votre dogmatisme a eu des égal que votre
indifférence quant à l'aggravation de la
situation financière des communes qu'il
provoquait cette aventure qui n'est
malheureusement pas fini à copro mais à
compromis la sérénité de relations entre
les parents et la communauté éducative
je leur viendrai pas sur les 15 millions
d'euros qui ont été présentés lors de
l'amendement hier et qui a fait que nous
avons refusé ce budget de l'enseignement
supérieur 15 millions d'euros fait
présenter lors des services de la séance
je veux pas parler d'amateurisme je ne
veux pas mais on peut s'interroger par
rapport à cela va-t-il fallait-il
ajouter à ses premières crises la
problématique des ABCD de l'égalité la
promotion d'une fameuse Ligne Azur
annulée par le Conseil d'État le 15
octobre dernier je cite l'arrêt du
Conseil d'État Cili cette ligne écrit-il
présenter l'usage de drogue comme
susceptible de faire tomber les
inhibitions et comme purement associé à
des mouvements des moments festifs sans
mentionner
l'inégalité de cette pratique voilà une
initiative je pourrais ajouter d'autres
choses je veux pas rentrer dans la
polémique mais madame la ministre qui ne
risque pas de restaurer la confiance des
parents dans le système éducatif et vous
savez comme cette confiance est
nécessaire
recentrions-nous sur les véritables
missions de l'école enfin comme si cela
ne suffisait pas on entend ces jours-ci
parler de supprimer la notation des
élèves pourquoi pas il s'est un effet
pourquoi pas ça peut avoir un effet moi
je suis pas de ceux je suis un défenseur
du socle commun des compétences et je ne
suis pas de ceux qui pensent que la
notation quelque chose de fondamental je
suis j'ai un avis très partagé par
rapport à cela mais avant de réfléchir
là-dessus il y aura peut-être des
expérimentations à faire à mettre en
place ou à prolonger vis-à-vis de cela
on peut s'interroger sur cette notation
on peut s'interroger vous avez raison
sur ce redoublement qui est inefficace
mais on doit aussi s'interroger sur les
programmes scolaires sur ces
encyclopédisme qui est trop fort sur le
fait des inspecteurs généraux qui sont
aussi peut-être trop axés sur leurs
discipline sur ce rôle important je
pense que les disciplines ne sont pas un
moyen en soi mais un support en
conclusion madame la ministre
l'éducation nationale a besoin de temps
ne clivez pas ne supprimez pas ce qu'il
faut fonctionner ou c'est le motif que
c'était la droite qu'il a fait
l'éducation nationale mérite à consensus
politique pour rassurer les enseignants
en doute les parents en crainte et les
élèves trop souvent en échec vous
l'aurez compris le groupe UMP adoptera
les crédits de la mission si les
amendements de nos excellents
rapporteurs
Gérard Longuet et Jean-Claude Karl
seront adoptés je vous remercie merci
la parole est à Michel Savin pour 8
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur
nous abordons une partie importante du
budget de l'État avec l'examen des
crédits de l'enseignement scolaire
dans le montant s'élève à 65 milliards
d'euros
malgré les moyens considérables
mobilisés par la puissance publique les
insuffisances de notre système éducatif
sont bien connus et perdure
ce constat est partagé par un très grand
nombre d'acteurs et partenaires de
l'éducation nationale
et je ne peux alors que déplorer la
faiblesse des solutions retenues dans ce
projet de budget pour remédier à une
situation qui conduit au creusement des
inégalités entre les élèves
le CDE insiste régulièrement sur le
manque de pertinence des méthodes
d'enseignement utilisées en France
le diagnostic est le même pour la Cour
des comptes et son premier président
Monsieur Didier Migaud
qui constate que les résultats
insuffisants que nous enregistrons nous
proviennent pas d'un manque de moyens
budgétaire ni d'un manque d'enseignants
mais d'une gestion défaillante de ses
moyens
bien que cette conviction soit partagée
au-delà des sensibilités politiques la
seule réponse que le gouvernement met en
avant pour répondre à l'urgence de
réforme de notre modèle scolaire c'est
une augmentation du nombre d'enseignants
en l'absence de véritables réflexion sur
l'utilisation des moyens de l'éducation
nationale sur la redéfinition du métier
d'enseignant et les méthodes
d'apprentissage des connaissances de
base cette mesure semble bienveillement
coûteuse
notre société ne peut faire l'économie
d'un débat de fond sur la question de
l'utilisation des moyens alloués à
l'éducation il est la condition d'une
réforme du système scolaire efficace et
surtout viable sur le long terme
Madame le Ministre le constat est le
même concernant le contrat
d'apprentissage dont le président de la
République a pourtant fait un enjeu
majeur de son quinquennat
le gouvernement a annoncé en 2013 son
objectif de faire progresser le nombre
d'apprentis de 435 à 500 000 à l'horizon
malheureusement la réalité s'est révélée
bien éloignée de ses annonces puisqu’en
2013 justement le nombre de contrat
signés a chuté de 8% par rapport à 2012
il a encore diminué de 14% au cours de
l'année 2014
ce type de formation assure pourtant aux
jeunes des débouchés professionnels dans
70% des cas
or à la conjoncture difficile s'ajoute
un manque de visibilité pour les
entreprises qui ne les encourage pas à
conclure ce type de contrat
réduction du budget de l'apprentissage
de 20% en 2013
diminution du crédit d'impôt lié à la
présence d'apprentis réforme de la taxe
d'apprentissage et concurrence des
emplois d'avenir
toutes ces mesures ont contribué à
décourager les employeurs potentiels
de plus certaines des normes techniques
administratives encadrant la conclusion
des contrats d'apprentissage sont
aujourd'hui trop rigides pour les
besoins des entreprises
là encore madame la ministre un travail
de fond s'impose sur ce sujet et les
mesures prises par le gouvernement ne
sont pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu
si des objectifs chiffrés ont été fixés
je déplore l'absence de propositions
fortes visant à inciter les jeunes et
les entreprises à s'engager sur ces
contrats d'apprentissage
et ce qui est vrai et mon collègue vient
d'en parler ce qui est vrai pour
l'apprentissage
les aussi pour la profession la
formation professionnelle
nous sommes confrontés et nous savons
tous un double problème
cela formation professionnelle ces
formations sont malheureusement
mal valorisées ou très peu valorisé et
elle n'attire pas assez les jeunes
alors pour terminer madame la ministre
peut-être
une petite lueur de d'espoir lorsqu'on
après l'annonce du Premier ministre d'un
engagement étatique à long terme dans le
financement des activités périscolaires
annonce qu'il y a quelques peu rassurer
les élus locaux
cette participation aux fondamental qui
a pour objectif d'encourager des
collectivités à proposer aux enfants des
activités de qualité
et devenu indispensable de nombreuses
communes pour offrir ce service à tous
les élèves
dans un contexte de baisse constant des
dotations de l'État la lisibilité de
l'action gouvernementale sur ce sujet
est indispensable alors même que cette
question est de nature à impacté
lourdement le budget des communes d'une
manière générale un effort de clarté
doit être entrepris lorsque des
décisions sont prises au niveau de
l'Etat décisions qui ont un impact
direct sur les finances des
collectivités locales
dernier exemple en date qui peut-être
est passé un peu inaperçu c'est la
décision qui a été imposée aux communes
avec la prise en charge de
l'organisation de la demi-journée de
consultation des enseignants en octobre
cette prise en charge encore une fois de
plus représenter un coût injustifié pour
les communes dans un contexte budgétaire
déjà délicat et peu lisible
le budget 2015 de l'éducation doit
constituer selon les mots de Madame la
Ministre un marqueur de l'importance que
le gouvernement accorde à l'éducation
comme levier de progrès et de réussite
une réforme en profondeur du système
éducatif des mesures fortes en faveur de
l'apprentissage et une plus grande
lisibilité de l'action gouvernementale
voilà trois points qui font défaut
madame la ministre au budget 2015 pour
faire du système français un véritable
levier de progrès et de réussite merci
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Madame Françoise carton pour 7 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues madame la ministre
vous nous soumettez aujourd'hui un
projet de budget pour l'enseignement
scolaire qui se caractérise ainsi un
budget ambitieux pour l'année 2015 en
hausse de près de 3 % qui traduit bien
la priorité accordée à la jeunesse
affirmée par le Président de la
République et respecté depuis deux ans
un budget courageux disons-le dans le
contexte financier que notre pays
difficile que notre pays subit je salue
ce budget de l'enseignement scolaire il
redevient le premier de la nation devant
le remboursement de la dette enfin
dirais-je un budget cohérent qui
soutient les grands objectifs de la loi
de refondation de l'école adopter ici
même il y a maintenant deux ans
ce budget concrétise en effet la
création des milliers de postes avec la
première priorité celle accordée à
l'enseignement primaire car oui jusqu'à
présent notre pays dépense 34% de moins
pour un élève de l'enseignement primaire
que pour un élève du secondaire le
rattrapage entreprise 2012 depuis 2012
est indispensable tout à fait
indispensable et urgent alors monsieur
le rapporteur pour avis quand vous
écrivez qu'il s'agit là d'un schéma
d'emploi dangereux et difficilement
soutenable je vous cite cela doit
signifier que vous proposer la fin des
recrutements d'enseignants dans ce cas
vous devrez alors expliquer sur le
terrain la fameuse règle du non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
voire plus si j'ai bien compris allez
donc expliquer que oui il normal de
fermer tel ou telle classe pour
rationaliser les dépenses mais bien sûr
cela va améliorer le système public
d'éducation allez expliquer que oui
toutes ces petites écoles rurales de
montagne en particulier coûte cher et
qu'elles devront être supprimées
monsieur Longuet a l'air prêt à le faire
d'après ce que j'ai entendu allez donc
expliquer que oui l'accès à l'école
maternelle pour les moins de trois ans
dans les secteurs difficiles
représentent un coût inutile ceci bien
sûr dans l'intérêt de l'enfant
d'ailleurs nous avons entendu le vieux
refrain de l'école maternelle qui ne
serait plus qu'une garderie et pourquoi
pas revenons à créer ces fameux jardins
d'éveil dans le succès a été éblouissant
lorsque vous rencontrerez les élus dans
le cadre de vos prochaines élections
dites-leur que le programme plus de
maîtres que de classe consomme trop de
poste et un seul maître par classe cela
suffit bien même avait 30 élèves il
faudra l'expliquer sur nos territoires
mes chers collègues faire preuve de
courage et préconisé des solutions
applicables ici mais seulement pour les
autres et sans doute pas dans votre
circonscription mais allons plus loin
puisque vous semblez admettre dans le
même temps qu'un effort est nécessaire
pour le premier degré et que vous dites
je cite vous opposez fermement à la
poursuite des recrutements massifs menés
par Madame la Ministre
dites haut et fort qu'il faudra
supprimer des postes dans le second
degré qu'il faudra revoir la carte des
options très coûteuses en moyen et
parfois source d'inégalités entre les
établissements
reconnaissez que le nouveau président de
votre formation politique Monsieur
Sarkozy pendant sa campagne interne a
annoncé la suppression de 30% de poste
faites preuve de responsabilité et aller
expliquer pourquoi et comment vous allez
supprimer 200
000 enseignants en France parce que
c'est bien ce chiffre hallucinant qui
est derrière ces 30% de suppression de
poste
alors oui mes chers collègues
impressions le budget qui nous est
présenté à sa juste valeur un budget qui
comme les années précédentes donne les
moyens nécessaires à l'école de la
République à ses enseignants à ses
élèves afin de relever le défi
primordial je dis bien primordial pour
le devenir et la prospérité de notre
pays le défi de la connaissance partagée
par tous un budget qui va également
continuer d'accompagner cette formation
des maîtres enfin rétabli après le
naufrage perpétré lors du précédent
quinquennat certaines choses sans doute
dans les esprits sont améliorés et
Jacques Bernard manier en a parlé mieux
que moi sur la création des espèces
justement en saluant cette formidable
avancée pour la pratique et l'exercice
difficile du métier d'enseignant un
métier qui s'apprend et ne s'improvise
pas
et puis dans ce budget saluant la hausse
importante de 6,6% pour l'accompagnement
des élèves en situation de handicap
c'est l'école inclusive voulue par la
refondation de l'école ces trois
dernières années le nombre d'élèves
ainsi accueillis à plus que doublé et ce
sont chaque année plus de 350 nouveaux
postes d'accompagnants élèves en
situation d'handicap qui sont pourvus
ainsi que la déprécarisation de ces
emplois
enfin ce budget prend en compte la
recondition du fond d'amorçage pour la
mise en place des rythmes scolaires
c'était nécessaire
indispensable et nous en parlerons un
peu plus tard dans la discussion cette
mesure va s'inscrire dans la durée comme
la indiquée Monsieur le Premier Ministre
au Congrès des Maires il s'agit là d'un
signal positif adressé à tous ses élus
qui se sont investis avec succès pour la
mise en place de cette réforme alors à
ce moment de la discussion beaucoup
d'interventions des uns et des autres et
en particulier de Messieurs les
rapporteurs portent sur les difficultés
de notre école qui ne permet pas
toujours à tous les enfants qui lui sont
confiés de réussir un parcours scolaire
citoyen culturel sésame d'une insertion
dans la vie sociale et professionnelle
mais je voudrais conclure sur une note
plus optimiste en vue incitant toutes et
tous à aller voir le film qui sort
aujourd'hui les héritiers vous y
rencontrerez une enseignante formidable
professeur d'histoire-géographie qui
aime enseigner qui donne envie qui donne
le goût du travail qui permet à chacun
de ces élèves même les plus en
difficulté même les plus difficiles
d'entreprendre elle leur dit vous avez
le droit d'être reconnu d'être des gens
bien c'est vous les héritiers de
l'histoire pour ces élèves là pour tous
les élèves qui méritent que l'on croit
en eux pour cette professeure et pour
toutes celles et ceux qui innovent
s'accrochent le budget de l'Éducation
nationale ne sera jamais une dépense
exorbitante mais en investissement
indispensable pour notre avenir c'est ce
que vous portez madame les ministres
c'est ce budget là que nous voulons
voter et non pas un budget amputé merci
ma chère collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Serge Dassault
pour 8 minutes mon cher collègue
monsieur le Président
Madame le Ministre je suis le rapporteur
il faut admettre que notre éducation
nationale n'est plus adaptée aux besoins
de notre temps la formation scolaire
devrait à la fois enseigner et lutter
préparer tous les jeunes à devenir des
adultes capables de gagner leur vie en
ayant été formé à un métier ce qui est
loin d'être le cas c'est l'école
primaire qui doit enseigner à tous les
enfants les fondamentaux le savoir lire
écrire compter tout en leur donnant des
préceptes de morale contrairement à de
nombreux pays dans
du coup du travail de l'effort de la
discipline du respect des autres de la
vie en société or toutes les élections
ont disparues plus de redoublement plus
de sanctions plus de récompense plus
d'examen de classement et bientôt
j'espère que non plus de notes plus de
certificats d'études pour passer du
primaire au collège supprimer par des
Crêts en 89 de François Mitterrand plus
de nécessité de passer le brevet pour
entrer au lycée tous les bacheliers
intègres je vais citer sans sélection et
pour finir malheureusement le nombre
jeunes l'équipe deux ans après sans
avoir reçu la moindre formation
professionnelle c'est ainsi que 150
000 jeunes quittent chaque année
l'éducation nationale et deviennent
inactifs voir les délinquants coupant
service militaire ne vient plus sortir
de
une activité à cause de Jacques Chirac
contrairement à de nombreux pays où les
jeunes travaillent pour intégrer les
meilleures classes les meilleures écoles
les meilleures universités la
suppression de toute sélection de toute
volonté de réussite de tout ambition
avec l'ampoule la mise en place du
collège unique par René Haby en 75 font
perdre la France tous ces espoirs le
développement futur et explique les 150
mille jeunes sortis sans formation
chaque année madame Venise seul certains
secteurs de formation d'ingénieurs de
chercheurs de formation médicale grandes
écoles comme polyéthique central va chez
d'autres grâce à une sélection difficile
pour pouvoir être reçue avoir une
excellente formation d'ingénieurs et des
gamins le collège unique Madame le
Ministre le collège unique
est une catastrophe elle m'écoute pas
mesdames le collège unique est une
catastrophe
il car il supprime la formation
professionnelle
en Allemagne ou le chômage
des jeunes et minimum ou la formation
professionnelle voisine avec information
au diplôme les études s'effectuent dans
deux collègues séparés après une
sélection effectuée à la sortie du
primaire pour la formation
professionnelle ou pour les diplôme les
palettes de l'ensemble René a bien
unifié les structures administratives du
premier cycle et c'est sa faute tout ça
qui sont devenus tous des collèges et
mes fins la scolarité en filière à
l'époque qui devient différenciée c'est
le collège unique avec l'unification de
toutes les formations en un seul
programme sans aucune possibilité de
choix pour les élèves or tous les élèves
ne peuvent pas assimiler les mêmes
connaissances car mais comme il n'y a
plus de suivi
qui ne comprennent pas ils sortent du
collège à 16 ans sans aucune possibilité
de trouver un emploi et des jeunes
malheureusement inactifs et souvent
délinquants alors qu'ils auraient aimé
pouvoir apprendre à métier on en prend
un apprentissage à 14 ans comme le font
les Allemands et bien d'autres mais
malheureusement l'éducation nationale ne
s'intéresse pas à l'apprentissage il y a
alternance qui sont contrôlés par les
Chambres de Commerce et d'entreprises en
portant la durée de la scolarité Madame
le Ministre jusqu'à 18 ans pour ceux qui
à ces cages n'ont aucune formation cela
éviterait que ces jeunes qui sont des
collègues à 16 ans ne soit abandonnés à
eux-mêmes et ce qui permettrait de
continuer à les suivre dans leur
scolarité pour leur apprendre enfin une
formation professionnelle c'est ce que
font les missions locales financées par
les communes agglomérations très peu
parlé de ça malheureusement
par récupération des jeunes perdus avec
beaucoup d'efficacité pour les sortir de
leur inactivité le bac et leur a
présenté comme indispensable pour admir
tous les jeunes alors qu'il n'est utile
qu'à ceux qui veulent faire d'études
supérieures ne sert à rien pour tous
ceux qui voudraient apprendre à métier
il est conduits certains délinquance il
faut que l'éducation nationale arrête de
se féliciter du nombre de résultats du
bac au bac qui conduit 150 000 jeunes
dans l'impasse total
voilà madame mimi sa situation est de la
vie dans nos communes
vécu comme maire de Corbeil-Essonnes et
qui m'a donné l'occasion de connaître
ses problèmes et de continuer à présider
la formation la mission locale
ce qui vous arrive là
c'est pas bien d'être mère de
Corbeil-Essonnes et pas si facile
je serai heureux de vous la faire
visiter Madame le Ministre cette mission
locale de montrer que le développement
de lakanaquence
de ces jeunes qui filent travailleraient
ne serait pas délinquants ces jeunes ne
laisse pas délinquants mais deviennent
parce qu'on n'aura pas appris un métier
ce n'est pas de leur faute permettez-moi
de vous dire madame le ministre mais si
vous pouviez vous-même
supprimer le collège unique vous seriez
la meilleure ministre de l'éducation
nationale que l'on aurait eu depuis
longtemps merci
merci mon chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Dominique
Bailly pour 5 minutes
sur le président madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues nous examinons donc
ce matin les crédits consacrés à
l'enseignement scolaire et je souhaite
saluer madame la ministre budget 2015
qui montre encore une fois la priorité
accordée par le gouvernement à la
jeunesse et à l'éducation
oui la mission enseignement scolaire
bénéficie bénéficie cette année d'une
hausse de
2,56 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement compte 64,8 milliards j'y
reviendrai mon cher collègue et oui une
augmentation de plus de 1 milliard
d'euros est assigné est à souligner
surtout en cette période de contraintes
budgétaire et je constate avec
satisfaction madame la ministre comme
l'ensemble des sénateurs de mon groupe
que ce budget devient donc le premier
poste de dépenses de dépenses mon cher
collègue de l'État
pourquoi parce que nous ne pouvons
l'ignorer notre système scolaire est
imparfait étant un conforter oui les
inégalités sociales c'est pourquoi mes
chers collègues refontaient l'école de
la République est une urgence et je me
félicite donc oui je me répète que les
crédits 2015 s'inscrivent dans la lignée
de la loi pour la refondation de l'école
de la République et plus largement de
l'action du Gouvernement en la matière
depuis 2012
9421 postes
9421 postes seront créés en 2015 ce qui
permettra de remplacer tous les départs
à la retraite de reconstruire la
formation des enseignants et notamment
de rétablir l'année de formation
initiale et enfin d'améliorer
l'accompagnement des élèves par la
création de postes d'enseignants
d'auxiliaires de vie et de personnel
médico-sociaux j'y reviendrai et oui mes
chers collègues ces créations de postes
participent de la volonté de revaloriser
le métier d'enseignant
je déplore je déplore oui mes chers
collègues rapporteurs les amendements
déposés qui visent à revenir sur ses
créations de postes proposées par le
gouvernement et je veux ici insister sur
la priorité donnée au primaire comme ma
collègue Françoise Cartron à l'instant
rappelons que depuis 2012 3000 classes
ont été ouvertes 3000 classes en plus de
1000 écoles et oui 1000 écoles avaient
été fermées entre 2010 et 2012 et les
moyens louaient l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui permettront de développer la
scolarisation des enfants de moins de 3
ans le rôle de l'école maternelle est
fondamentale pour la suite du parcours
scolaire et le gouvernement a donc fixé
madame la ministre comme objectif que
30% d'enfants de moins de 3 ans doivent
être scolarisés à l'issue du quinquennat
et cette année 300 postes s'ajouteront
397 qui ont déjà été créés à la rentrée
de 2013 et ses moyens alloués vont nous
aider à développer le dispositif plus de
mettre que de classe et oui les moyens
alloués vont aussi renforcer les Raz je
le disais dans mon introduction la lutte
contre les inégalités sociales et le
grand défi de l'école de la République
et je me félicite donc des moyens loués
à la lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
que certains de mes collègues ont évoqué
et aussi à la réforme de l'éducation
prioritaire pour laquelle 1100 postes
pour le premier degré et 881 pour le
second degré devrait être mobilisé en
2015 ce budget donne aussi des moyens à
la scolarisation des enfants en
situation de handicap madame la ministre
et je voudrais insister là-dessus le
nouveau statut des accompagnants des
élèves en situation de handicap
contribue à la professionnalisation de
l'accompagnement de ses enfants et
c'était une demande 5000 auxiliaires de
vie scolaire ont donc vu leur contrat
précaire transformé en CDI à la rentrée
2014 et 28000 autres bénéficieront
bientôt de cette mesure
plus de 280 millions d'euros inscrits
sur le titre 2 du projet de loi de
finance pour 2015 permettront donc de
financer plus de 11000 aesh donc 350
emplois créés à la rentrée 2014 et 350 à
la rentrée 2015 enfin comme certains de
mes collègues je voudrais revenir sur
les fondamentales pour la réforme des
rythmes scolaires oui un amendement
socialiste à l'article 55 auquel madame
la ministre vous avez réservé un accueil
favorable à l'Assemblée nationale a été
adoptée et cet amendement étendu le fond
pour l'année 2015-2016 à toutes les
communes dès lors dès lors qu'elles ont
un projet éducatif territorial comme le
préciser mon collègue Jean-Bernard
Meunier et le l'amendement que nous
allons examiner tout à l'heure
concrétise oui l'engagement pris par le
Premier ministre lors du congrès des
maires c'est-à-dire pérenniser le fond
d'amorçage qui devient donc un fond de
soutien sans limitation de durée je
tiens à saluer madame la ministre
l'engagement du le gouvernement auprès
des élus locaux
adapter le rythme des apprentissages au
rythme de l'enfant était une nécessité
tout le monde le sait la réforme des
rythmes scolaires permet aussi un accès
de tous les enfants à des activités
périscolaires et constitue une mesure de
justice sociale j'ai mis en place cette
réforme dans ma commune dès la rentrée
scolaire 2013 madame la ministre et les
retours sont très positifs de la part
des enseignants des parents mais surtout
surtout des enfants la mise en oeuvre de
cette réforme des nouvelles activités
périscolaires et sans conteste un enjeu
pour les collectivités locales et la
pérennisation du fondamorçage est donc
un excellent signal tout comme la
responsabilisation des communes en la
matière activité périscolaires qui
doivent être de qualité et non une
simple garderie pour conclure mes chers
collègues progression les crédits
progression des moyens humains
orientation du président de la
République confirmé ce budget porte donc
Madame la Ministre une véritable
ambition politique au service de
l'éducation nationale je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
madame Claudine Lepage pour 4 minutes ma
chère collègue
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues les crédits de cette
mission traduisent cette année encore la
priorité donnée à l'éducation et je m'en
réjouis mais j'ai un autre motif de
satisfaction madame la ministre la
première réunion interministérielle
toute récente sur l'enseignement
français à l'étranger autour de vous
madame la ministre du ministre des
Affaires étrangères étaient réunis les
acteurs du réseau d'enseignements
français à l'étranger depuis mon arrivée
au Sénat je demande une plus grande
coopération entre les deux ministères et
j'avais fait voter un amendement dans ce
sens dans la loi sur la refondation de
l'école je m'en réjouis donc tout
particulièrement notre réseau
d'établissements d'enseignement français
homologué le plus grand au monde avec
494 établissements scolarisés en 330 000
élèves et précieux et doit être
sauvegardé
tout autant parce qu'il apporte un
service d'éducation de qualité
exceptionnelle aux familles expatriées
expatriées au sens étymologique du terme
et parce qu'il est l'un des outils de
notre politique d'influence en
scolarisant 200 000 élèves étrangers
mais ce formidable atout pour notre pays
doit faire face à un double défi
quantitatif avec une croissance
constante de ces effectifs plus 18,5% en
5 ans qualitatif aussi tente au regard
de l'exigence croissante des familles
que de la concurrence internationale
c'est pour répondre à ces défis que le
plan d'action en faveur de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger de
novembre 2013 a mis en place ce
mécanisme de concertation
au cours de cette première réunion
madame la ministre la nécessaire
coordination entre les deux ministères a
donc été réaffirmé ainsi il sera
organisé une conférence annuelle des
ressources humaines et des moyens afin
de disposer d'une vision stratégique
pour le développement du réseau par une
meilleure allocation des moyens en
fonction des priorités diplomatiques
françaises elle devrait aussi permettre
une gestion plus fine des ressources
humaines notamment grâce à une
anticipation salutaire du traitement des
demandes de détachement je salue cette
initiative même si j'ai bien compris que
le nombre d'enseignants détachés n'a pas
vocation à augmenter en dépit de la
croissance continue du réseau à
l'étranger
il est également prévu d'assouplir les
procédures d'homologation
j'entends bien qu'il ne s'agit pas de
revenir sur les critères pédagogiques
mais vous avez aussi rappelé que les
détachements ne constituaient pas une
condition nécessaire à l'homologation
cette décoration m'interpelle d'autant
plus que dans le même temps il a bien
été convenu de renforcer le rôle de
votre ministère dans l'accompagnement
pédagogique du réseau
pouvez-vous me préciser comment il
assumera ce rôle par ailleurs est-il
envisageable dans le cadre de l'audit
régulier de recourir à des retraits
d'homologation en cas de manquement
avéré
comme vous le savez je dois remettre
tout prochainement avec le député
Corderie un rapport sur les moyens pour
limiter la hausse des frais de scolarité
dans le réseau nous envisageons toutes
les pistes et notamment la possibilité
d'ajouter aux critères d'homologation
strictement pédagogique une obligation
de bonne gouvernance et de transparence
dans la gestion des établissements qu'en
pensez-vous madame la ministre
pour conclure je rebondirai sur votre
objectif de valorisation des innovations
pédagogiques dans le réseau en les
diffusant entre les établissements
homologués je ne doute pas qu'une
diffusion de ces innovations soit tout
aussi souhaitable entre les réseaux en
France et à l'étranger elle pourrait
notamment être assurée par une plus
grande mobilité des enseignants d'autant
plus facile s'il existait une véritable
valorisation de l'expérience acquise
dans le réseau à l'étranger une
expérience à l'international et toujours
un atout quel que soit l'emploi comment
pensez-vous que l'éducation nationale
puisse davantage prendre en compte de
cette dimension je vous remercie madame
la ministre merci ma chère ma collègue
la parole est à Madame Dominique Gillot
pour 4 minutes de ma chère collègue
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues voici le deuxième
budget de la mise en oeuvre de la
refondation de l'école réforme majeure
accompagnée d'un budget sanctuarisé et
renforcé année après année pour assurer
la priorité donner à l'école par le
gouvernement votre prédécesseur Vincent
payant avait conçu la création des ESP
comme levier principal de la refondation
ces objets à créer école dans
l'université et avec l'université
répondent aux questions indispensables
pour transmettre les connaissances et
les compétences que faut-il savoir pour
être enseignant que faut-il savoir faire
ou connaître pour être enseignant créer
le ESP dans l'université c'est s'assurer
d'une réelle pluridisciplinarité
génératrice d'une approche
transdisciplinaire il faut que les
universités considèrent les ESP comme
pilier essentiel de la construction du
savoir et de sa diffusion et non comme
résiduelle ou complémentaire ces
nouvelles structure
doivent se performer des progrès reste à
faire ça a été dit les difficultés sont
réelles leur évocation doit poursuivre
l'objectif de les surmonter
c'est la création d'un tronc commun dans
la formation des maîtres qui développera
une culture commune à tous les futurs
enseignants basés sur une pratique
collective et réflexive les services
académiques qui ont toutes leurs places
aux côtés des équipes universitaires et
l'acquisition de ce tronc commun doit
être évaluée dans le cadre du concours
pour cela je salue la volonté rien
affirmée du ministère de créer de
véritables équipes pluridisciplinaires
mêlant enseignant chercheurs et tuteurs
de stage demain éducateur animateur
encadrant du temps périscolaire c'est en
atteignant ces objectifs que l'on
passera vraiment des ufm aux ESP c'est
cette place particulière dans
l'université qui permettra de renforcer
les relations entre le praticien et le
chercheur chaque établissement chaque
enseignant chaque intervenant chaque
étudiant est en réalité un laboratoire
faisant du chercheur inclinicien la
recherche doit aider à sur les
prophéties auto-réalisatrices en
favorisant la co-construction des
savoirs le travail d'équipe et par suite
la réussite de tous améliorer les
méthodes pédagogiques repenser les
schémas d'apprentissage sont autant de
défis que la recherche relève et c'est
en cela que les universités doivent
appréhender leur responsabilité
particulière dans le fonctionnement
scientifique des ESP la formation des
maîtres ainsi repenser et
particulièrement originale car elle
comporte une assignation à la
coopération qui se traduit par
l'alternance intégrative cette
professionnalisation progressive donnera
aux futurs enseignants l'appareillage
leur permettant de disposer de l'aisance
professionnelle de confronter les
apprentissages à la pratique de poser
des questions à des termes qui les
rendent très tard
c'est cette professionnalisation
progressive qui est à même de
diversifier les profils des futurs
maîtres pourtant le concours pose deux
problèmes tout d'abord sa place dans le
cursus ou plutôt sa place au milieu d'un
cursus entre le master 1 et le Master 2
ne faudrait-il pas favoriser des modules
complémentaires en licence afin de
développer une orientation prescriptive
en master le second problème c'est que
le concours est de tout temps
traditionnellement vecteur de
reproduction des élites alors il s'agit
bien de changer les habitudes et de
mieux intégrer ce concours au processus
pédagogique afin de faire de l'année du
Master 2 une année de formation plus
qu'une année de préparation au concours
la pluridisciple
pluridisciplinarité le travail en équipe
et la diversification des profils sont
bien les clés d'une professionnalisation
du concours et donc de justice réelle
dans l'accès à la fonction d'enseignant
avec les ESP l'école l'intégratrice de
demain est en marche c'est la même qui
offre bien plus qu'apprendre à compter
lire et écrire cette école qui postule
que tous les enfants sont capables qui
veut la réussite et l'épanouissement de
chacun à travers ses propres compétences
le gouvernement y met les moyens
nécessaires ce projet de financement en
atteste et c'est pour cela que nous
allons le voter voilà pour les
discussions ce matin consacrée au crédit
de la mission enseignement scolaire à
l'éducation nationale l'une des
priorités du quinquennat de François
Hollande qui rappelons-le a promis la
création de 60 000 postes en 5 ans une
politique qui évidemment a un coût et à
laquelle s'oppose notamment à la
majorité sénatoriale de droite vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site sur
publicena.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 15h pour l'audition de Marylise le
branchu et André Vallini les ministres
entendus pour préparer le projet de loi
notre nouvel organisation territoriale
de la République très bonne journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires